[Música]
se fortalece el aseo ruso sobre la
ciudad de ucraniana de mariopolis sus
alrededores luego de que fracasar el
segundo día de cese del fuego en el que
iban a ser evacuados civiles el
presidente voló divino que el ejército
ruso Buscar a bombardear la estratégica
ciudad de odesa y confirmó que el
Aeropuerto Internacional de Venecia fue
destruido
la presidencia francesa informó que tras
una conversación entre immanuel macuy
Vladimir Putin el jefe del kremlin
aseguró que obtendrá sus objetivos por
la negociación o por la guerra a su vez
el presidente de Turquía Perdón le pidió
a Putin usase inmediato de las
hostilidades a lo que Putin respondió
que las acciones militares solo se
detendrán siquiera abandona la
resistencia y acepta las demandas rusas
que son más de 1.5 millones de personas
las que han tenido que huir de Ucrania
hacia países vecinos en los 11 días de
ofensiva rusa Polonia afirmó que ya ha
recibido a más de un millón de personas
acnur señaló que se trata del mayor
flujo de refugiados desde la Segunda
Guerra Mundial
en Francia 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan la jornada soy
Valentina Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos damos inicio en Ucrania
puntualmente en la ciudad de mariopo El
donde fracasó por segundo día el intento
de evacuación de civiles mientras que
Rusia y Ucrania se acusan mutuamente de
incumplir El Alto al fuego temporal los
residentes de esta ciudad se encuentran
rodeados por las tropas rusas con
escasez de agua sin gas ni electricidad
entre tanto el presidente
bolodimirselensky confirmó que cohetes
rusos destruyeron por completo el
aeropuerto civil de vinicia en el centro
del país en esta localidad vivían unas
360 mil personas hasta antes de la
invasión rusa
acaban de informar sobre un ataque con
misiles en Venecia ocho cohetes ataque
con misiles contra nuestra ciudad contra
nuestro pacífica y buena vinicia que
nunca ha amenazado a Rusia de ninguna
manera duro cínico el aeropuerto fue
completamente destruido Sí
también advirtió que las fuerzas rusas
están planeando atacar la ciudad de
Odessa una vulva histórica en la costa
del mar Negro
Moscú ya ocupado en gran medida la otra
costa de Ucrania en el mar de azufre y
pretende ampliar la invasión al sur del
país más detalles en el siguiente
reporte
los residentes apilan sacos de arena y
hacen cócteles Molotov mientras se
preparan para defender su hogar están
cada vez más seguros de que las sureña
ciudad de Odessa podría ser el próximo
objetivo de Rusia
estoy aquí para proteger Mi ciudad Estoy
cocinando y llenando sacos de arena mi
casa está allí hay que defenderla así
nos han educado al tomar el control de
la ciudad portuaria los rusos
bloquearían a los ucranianos de acceso a
las aguas pues ya Perdieron el control
sobre la mayor parte de la costa de
assoft
hoy no hay combates en Odessa Pero hay
barcos militares cerca en el mar Negro
suponemos que el enemigo se está
preparando eso es lo que pensamos el
enemigo está preparando una operación de
desembarco en nuestra ciudad
el ataque podría venir desde el mar
Negro pero también por tierra desde la
cercana ciudad de gerson o desde el
cielo Pony se están preparando para
bombardear odesa Odessa los rusos
Siempre han venido a Odessa y han
recibido una calidad bienvenida y ahora
que bombas cayendo sobre Odessa
artillería contra odesa misiles
disparados contra odesa será un crimen
de guerra será un crimen histórico el
alcalde de Odessa pide una zona de
exclusión aérea para proteger a los
cerca del millón de residentes que viven
en la ciudad la otan dice que es opción
está fuera de la mesa el asedio también
se intensificó sobre kiev y sus
alrededores
de irping a 25 kilómetros de la capital
ucraniana fue intensamente bombardeado
por la artillería al tiempo que los
civiles buscaban huir y refugiarse a 40
kilómetros al sur de kiev en una de las
pocas salidas de la capital que aún
están habilitadas se encuentra sijil
pabellón periodista de nuestra cadena
hermana en francesa Desde allí nos dio
más detalles de lo que se ha vivido en
las últimas horas
estos son los efectos concretos de la
invasión militar de Rusia sobre
ucraniados
estamos en la ciudad de Brasil a 40
kilómetros al sur de la capital
ucraniana
y lo que ven en las imágenes es una
escuela que fue alcanzada por un misil
Ruso aquí
una instrucción total de este edificio
además todavía hay a mis pies libros
escolares abrigos por lo que podemos
imaginar que en el número de Muertos fue
un par de docenas
Esta es una ciudad que fue golpeada
desde el principio de la ofensiva porque
es una ciudad donde hay tropas
permanentemente y también hay un
aeropuerto militar el objetivo era que
la ofensiva rusa tomara este aeropuerto
para poder lanzar asaltos desde este
aeropuerto hubo una represalia por parte
de las fuerzas ucranianas y muchos
muertos y sabemos que el Mouse operandi
que tuvo lugar aquí fue un equipo de
saboteadores rusos que estaba infiltrado
es un modus operandi que se ha extendido
mucho desde el inicio de la ofensiva en
la ciudad de ucranianas y que atacaba
desde dentro por eso estaba este misil
podemos ver aquí el impacto del misil y
su violencia
Así que hoy esta ciudad es un frente
porque obviamente quiere estar rodeada
casi por completo sabemos que a pocos
kilómetros de donde estamos está este
frente donde se dice que las fuerzas
ucranianas están un poco llamadas así
que sentimos que esta compactadora
militar rusa está entrando en acción
llevamos unos instantes aquí ya hubo
varias sirenas de aviso y bombardeos
aéreos
para los habitantes de este municipio
que se han quedado Pues también les
puedo decir que hubo un Éxodo masivo y
lo entendemos al ver el grado de
destrucción en el lugar donde estamos en
plena calle en el centro de esta ciudad
para los que se quedaron bueno toda la
noche nos dijeron se quedaron en
refugios en sótanos en bodegas porque
había alertas de bombardeo
uno todo y una explosión Así que es una
situación precaria y refleja totalmente
lo que está sucediendo aquí en la ciudad
de satélite te lo Blas de kiev que es
gran región administrativa que abarca
varios cientos de kilómetros cuadrados
alrededor de quiebre
en medio del conflicto los esfuerzos
diplomáticos continúan pero parecen
infructuosos el presidente Vladimir
Putin habló telefónicamente con su
homólogo francés Emmanuel con el Primer
Ministro israelí naftal y bennett y con
el presidente Turco Reyes type erdon
mccon señale otras la llamada que el
líder del kremlin Indicó que obtendrá
sus objetivos por la negociación o por
la guerra al tiempo del mandatario galo
pidió que cesen las hostilidades y Putin
solicitó que los ucranianos tengan
disposición de diálogo para las
conversaciones que se reanudan mañana en
la frontera entre Polonia y belarús por
su parte tanto Turquía como Israel se
han ofrecido para mediar en el conflicto
erdogan le pidió a Putin un inmediato
alto del fuego y se ofreció para
encontrar vías para alcanzar la paz
previamente conversamos con Víctor Hey
fett profesor de la universidad estatal
de San Petersburgo que nos explicó si se
puede hablar de algún éxito diplomático
en medio del panorama que vive Ucrania
también en términos prácticos que se
puede esperar de las negociaciones que
se retoman el lunes y Cómo se
interpretan las afirmaciones de Putin de
obtener sus objetivos negociados o por
la guerra Me parece que el único éxito
por el momento es el hecho de que están
hablando o sea no deja no cierran la
puerta para poder alcanzar alguna
solución diplomática pero los resultados
directos siguió Por el momento no veo lo
que la atención es la propuesta de
Turquía y de Israel de ser intermediario
porque los dos países sobre todo Israel
parecen ser intermediarios perfectos A
diferencia de otros para ambos países
porque cumplen requisitos de confianza
en dos lados pero todavía hay que
esperar hasta que eso
este objetivo esté alcanzado
yo creo que eso interpreta así el
presidente ruso Está seguro ha sido de
entender que está absolutamente seguro
en que los objetivos militares de la
campaña si los está alcanzando entonces
no tiene ahora porque ceder en la
diplomacia pero si lo Proponen lo mismo
en la misma negociación estaría
dispuesto pero creo que él no está
pensando que país está perdiendo en el
conflicto Me parece que el único
resultado que pueden lograr por el
momento es lograr un cese del fuego de
hecho a entender Por qué el acuerdo
sobre el cese de fuego no fue cumplido y
elaborar mecanismos más fiables para que
funcionen los canales para la salud
humanitaria para la población civil yo
no creo que haya Habrá más receptores
por el momento pero eso es lo que sí
pueden y deberían alcanzar en la tercera
se cumplen 11 días de la ofensiva rusa
en Ucrania y Naciones Unidas confirmó
que hasta el momento hay 1.123 víctimas
entre muertos y heridos del lado
ucraniano no obstante el organismo
admitió que la cifra debe ser
considerablemente más alta entre tanto
las autoridades polacas señalaron que
esta nación ya ha recibido a más de un
millón de refugiados la agencia de la
ONU para los refugiados acnur que más
temprano cifró en 1.5 millones el número
de personas que han tenido que huir del
país Indicó que este es el Éxodo de
personas más rápido en Europa desde la
Segunda Guerra Mundial esta semana la
Unión Europea aprobó en una decisión
simple ascendentes otorgar el estatus de
protección especial para los refugiados
de la invasión rusa que permite a los
ucranianos moverse libremente por
cualquier estado del bloque Durante un
año y podrán prorrogar este permiso
especial por seis meses escuchemos a
filipo grande alto comisionado de la ONU
para los refugiados
sabemos que cientos de miles se está
moviéndose dentro de Ucrania incluyendo
aquí cruzando la frontera
Así que es muy probable que en los
próximos días el gran flujo de personas
continentes
y la represión rusa continúa dentro de
su territorio solo en la última jornada
han sido detenidas al menos 3.500
personas que protestan contra la guerra
el Ministerio del interior ruso señaló
que las manifestaciones no autorizadas
se llevaron a cabo en Moscú en San
Petersburgo y en otras ciudades del
total de detenciones 2500 Se produjeron
en la capital rusa el líder opositor
alexey naval niños todas sus
compatriotas a ignorar las prohibiciones
y salir a las calles para exigir el fin
de la invasión
este domingo continuaron las protestas
en diversas ciudades del mundo para
pedir el fin de la guerra en Ucrania en
lugares como París Roma y Londres en
Europa o en almati la ciudad más grande
de kazajistán cientos de personas
invadieron las calles con banderas y
símbolos ucranianos exigiendo al
presidente Vladimir Putin que cese la
ofensiva
y las muestras de condena internacional
a la guerra continúan llegando en las
últimas horas la red social tiktok
anunció que dejará de publicar videos
desde Rusia a su vez el servicio de
streaming Netflix dejará de funcionar
por su parte American Express se unió a
las plataformas de pago visa y
mastercard e informó que dejara de
operar tanto en territorio ruso como en
belarús en el ámbito cultural el
director musical del teatro bolshoy de
Moscú tu ganso Jeff anunció este domingo
que dejó su cargo a su vez condenó que
los artistas rusos estén siendo Víctimas
de ataques y discriminación
El Ejecutivo italiano al igual que otros
gobiernos europeos está actuando contra
los oligarcas rusos para presionar al
presidente Putin a dar marcha atrás en
su guerra confiscando super yates y
otras propiedades de lujo de
multimillonarios que figuran en las
listas de sanciones
156 millones de dólares en yates y
mansiones Ese es el botín que la policía
italiana tiene en su poder desde que
empezó a incautar las pertenencias de
oligarcas rusos como el yate del
propietario del grupo siderúrgico
severstall alexe y mordachov la policía
italiana acaba de incautar El Lady am un
yate valorado en 65 millones de euros
perteneciente al Alexa y mordachov
estacionado en imperia liguria noreste
de Italia de acuerdo con las recientes
sanciones de la Unión Europea la razón
de su inscripción en la lista de
sancionados este obligar que a
multimillonario está cerca del
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin después
de Alemania y Francia Italia pasa a la
fase activa de las sanciones de Rusia
adoptadas por la Unión Europea y Estados
Unidos la confiscación de propiedades
hace parte de una estrategia global de
presión sobre esta influyente y poderosa
élite económica la confiscación de
propiedades hace parte de una estrategia
global de presión sobre esta influente y
poderosa élite económica
esta noche les digo a los oligarcas
rusos y a los líderes corruptos que
estafan miles de millones de dólares a
este régimen violento no más
Estados Unidos quiero decir el
departamento de justicia de Estados
Unidos está reuniendo un grupo de
trabajo dedicado a perseguir los
crímenes de los oligarcas rusos nos
estamos uniendo a los aliados europeos
para encontrar y confiscar sus yates sus
apartamentos de lujo sus aviones
privados vamos a por sus ganancias
malavidas
en Estados Unidos como en Europa estos
grupos de trabajo delicados siguen
identificando los activos financieros y
bienes que pertenecen a más de 500
personalidades o entidades rusas
es todo por el momento en France 24 a
ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía y
los invitamos a continuar con nosotros
que regresamos en breve con más noticias
[Música]